ladies and gentlemen so much has been
dropping since midnight thank you so
much for clicking on this video if
you're here please leave a like after
snagging the seats the perfect seats i'm
so so fortunate right now if you happen
to catch us at amc universal for the
batman come say hi
ah got our tickets and now there's two
new tv spots that were unveiled by
warner brothers first one called new
friend that focuses more on catwoman and
another one that i saw going around on
twitter shared by the culture crave
twitter account that focuses more on
riddler download them as usual threw
them in a final cut and now we're going
to watch them together for the first
time then we're going to talk about it
afterwards the first thing we're going
to do is watch this like 30 second tv
spot called wingsuit see more batman in
the wing suit but then we'll just go
into the other ones right afterwards i
am so flipping excited for this movie
let's get into action
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
let's just go by veterans at first
legacy bruce
guy's hilarious
come
[Music]
new friend of yours
i'm not so sure
looks like you upset her
the bad and the cat
it's got a nice ring
let's get into some trouble
it'll be fun
you got a lot of cats
when i was seven my mother was murdered
maybe we're not so different after all
this aren't dangerous
who knows how many people touch us
i got nine of them
okay i can't get over this soundtrack
damn whoa
just say hello
holy [ __ ]
you're listening
it's all about the wings
damn
so monstrous for the sins of your father
what have you done
what have you done
oh
say it so bruce this is part one
i am digging the score so much yeah
yeah damn that was revealing it was
[Music]
he's like uh haunting nightmare it's
like his bruce wayne was uh told that
there's some monster in his closet that
has secrets coming out you know that's
kind of the vibe i got sort of
just no go away i don't want to know
what ghost bump in the night and scares
batman wake up bruce
thomas wayne was evil
who was in the court of house
yeah i got a lot from that we're hearing
that this movie is going to be pretty
complex and it's interesting getting
trailers of these two supporting
characters catwoman and riddler and how
they tie in with their relationship to
batman yet they're two very different
tones and they seem like they're telling
two different stories it's like with
catwoman you know you get some of her
backstory there about how her mother
died when she was seven but then you
also have this like one brief shot in
the trailer where batman is carrying
like a little girl so it seems like with
the riddler and kind of how batman's
been operating as of late he's got his
own vendetta he's escaping through being
batman and letting out his rage and
terrorizing
criminals but it doesn't seem like he's
really being a hero the ironic part that
at least i'm gathering from his
relationship with catwoman is that even
though she's catwoman the thief it looks
like he will find a way to
become more of a hero
through his dynamics with her and
perhaps actually helping out the
civilians of gotham as opposed to i want
to go out there and beat up some
criminals yeah and then when he is
dealing with like riddler which is like
the bigger sticks where there is sort of
like this terrorist to gotham at this
point which by the way i'm loving paul
dano's voice i i think i think potatoes
is actually pretty cool and uh
absolutely i know we were making her
jokes but i actually love uh just how
insanely ominous oh it's so monstrous
yeah in a way that very much fits
everything else we're seeing here yeah
well he's also saying in that trailer
like this is how the batman will end up
i'm sure uh there's a lot of people on
twitter making the joke of like the
batman and obviously not it's not gonna
end the franchise this is the beginning
of it perhaps it's more indicative of
the identity crisis that bruce wayne is
having right now it's like we've heard
andy circus talk about how bruce wayne
and batman are sort of like a jekyll and
hyde situation going on here and it
seems like if this is the year two of
batman that he's been operating on a
certain presumption of how his identity
as batman is and now he's realizing that
this is not the path that he should be
going down that he is not really a hero
so he's got the dual complexity of who
he is as bruce wayne in relation to
thomas wayne that the riddler is
exposing and how he's been as batman in
year two and it seems like this is sort
of the reflection both of these
characters will cause them to see upon
himself and i think that's why there's
so much focus on them and what their
purpose serves in terms of enhancing uh
the batman bruce wayne portrayal for
robert pattinson at least that's what
i'm gathering from the trailer yeah i
mean it feels as though they're almost
both in their own ways going to push
bruce into a corner where he has to
confront and acknowledge himself and
stop almost running away from the
circumstances of his life through this
guise of batman and i know robert
pattinson and others have talked about
how in this movie they're almost
approaching that like some kind of
addictive spiral like you said i think
it's an interesting note it almost
reminded me of a more fleshed out
version of the dark knight rises in the
sense that she is even though she also
has the catwoman you know cat burglar
thief thinks she she gives the more
populist motivation to bruce but in that
movie it's not a huge plugged in part of
the plot as much as what i've heard zoe
kravitz talk about but i actually
believe her this time because a lot of
actors say that but i actually believe
that we will see an exploration of that
character we've talked about the length
of this movie and all the different
moving parts and it really does feel
like from these ads they're so focused
in on certain supporting characters like
we will actually get what drives her to
become the catwoman that we all know and
love from the comics what that will be
in this movie in their own way both
catwoman and the riddler on whatever
dubious ends of the law they are are
both trying to expose secrets that will
ultimately lead to justice of some
twisted variety and i think that's a
really interesting triangle to create
because you got these three characters
who all have personas who are all going
after a version of justice and it's hard
to say at this point who's this gonna be
the right one and which one we're gonna
wind up between and i love that we have
those things to look forward to as well
as you know all the cool action and cool
visuals and stuff like that i'm
wondering with catwoman there's a femme
fatale quality to her at least in this
portrayal and especially knowing what
matt reeves is riffing on with in terms
of film genre we've seen carmine falcone
the mob boss shown in this in her her
segment of this trailer and there were
some set photos that were released of
her with carmine and i don't know what
that's supposed to mean i wonder if
she's like playing some type of role of
some like romantic character to him but
as a way to infiltrate something yeah
doing the double agent thing because you
got mob boss you're dealing with and you
got riddler who seems like he's got a
much bigger agenda so it's like and then
i feel like penguin is tied in with
carmine falcone
so i am curious to see like how this is
all gonna
i still don't know i still don't know
it's a big puzzle and it's uh what's so
funny this is
the actual plot yeah
because right now it does feel just like
a big gotham populated with a whole
bunch of characters yeah which is great
at the outset and it's nice to have the
mystery of this movie's gonna have a
thick plot over two hours and 55 minutes
so what's yeah what's that going to look
like
all right guys well thank you for being
here um
this is this is revealing super cool i
know yeah the the wingsuit stuff that
that look
it looked awesome
yeah great here you are locked off shots
please that was that was amazing it
looked really cool i love the way it
just means it's like he just pulls that
strap
and then it gets all tight and yeah
ready for flight
all right guys thank you so much for
being here yeah this was awesome
see you guys on the batman